poi perché sta già facendo i regali
ciao manca ancora mamma papà e di affari
regalo nasti che ricordi queste perché
sono turisti questi sono sembrano tanti
però realtà sono uno perché era materia
si crea e nulla si distrugge il
soggiorno se inserite ho passato tutto
il giorno a ricordarti nella canzone che
però non ascolta sti esatto esatto
questa è una mattonella in legno
mattonelle cos'è un quadro serigrafico
su legno della fotoni e di congedo ha
però non avete fatto insieme voi che
fatto miseno photoshoppata accanto a lui
è un dolore al cuore questo nome
no aspetta però che ti manca un pezzo
lui mi ha scritto perché tu o
dimenticato da tempo passaporto per
intende quindi quindi chiaro e cioè un
messaggino passaporto uguale ti amo
torniamo insieme cioè risaputo
all'aumento colorno senza reti
ricordiamo nel mondo chi eravamo e che
potremmo ritornare d'atto questa è bella
questa volta che perché così fa il
regalo più bello tra la pro ma non
scoiali questo ancora non la vita
instagram hashtag tristezza not indica
la tua invidia la mia forza tu rimarrai
solo nella vita di comodo perché sono
sette perché sono uno per ogni giorno
che siamo stati separati e 802 di 5
ma a proposito di regali allora io mi
sono però davanti ho già fatto la lista
lo tema regali da riciclare permetto di
dire in categorie categoria numero 1
spaventi alla lontana categoria numero 2
perdono ma non dimentico categoria
numero 3 quelli che sono già fatto il
regalo migliore congeliamo accoglie a
sorpresa ecco la sorpresa perfetto a
settimana mia faccia pure dei reperti da
riciclare
certo abbiamo abbiamo la famiglia di
coniglietti in ghisa che ci hanno fatto
l'anno scorso
poi abbiamo i fermacarte mezzo busto di
magalli quello molto bello e poi abbiamo
il casco per la pulizia dei denti con
l'era utile va bene senti ma invece
fabrizia scegliere letale è un tratto
qualcosa ma purtroppo fabrizi moccolo ma
il liquidatore della base dal bravo così
quest'anno niente record prima perfetto
a cavallo a posto ha poi sporto una cosa
il regalo quest'anno azzurra glielo file
dispiace proprio non ti prego no no mi
dispiace allora quella coperta già
ancora non si è ripresa da quando ha
scoperto che preferisci pesce legumi
curi fi sacrosanto piacere di farlo in
fettine va bene come come tu sai che
facciamo
ed eccolo perfetto ti guarda qua
pazzesca una tarantola sottovuoto top
senti allora tu comunque natale con i
tuoi però capodanno thorne piano si sono
ricordati che posso per firenze
quel medico di quindi parlo ieri ma chi
sono ragazzi ex l
esatto un telo oppure in ascolta perché
ci fa quei certificati medici per
capodanno
quindi quest'anno niente cartonati delle
dolomiti no quest'anno fingiamo una
diarrea ombrello proprio stop per 88 o
domani dobbiamo dire tutti era di natale
i regali non li faccio al massimo guarda
il 24 mattino no no no non ci si vuole
pure all'ultimo su una persona di merda
anche quest'anno pensa invece gli 800 12
di ancora parenti se lo farò ha fatto
abbastanza testi e molto ridere questa
forma d'arte grazie ciao ti aspetti
qualche reale perché non lo avrai te lo
dico l'avrei regali non avrei neanche
amici neanche amici